if you
had taken a [__] and wiped your ass
would you have washed your hands
and probably the one
you know what I mean I I don't how do
you wash one day one hand without
washing the other oh no you sound like
Confucius what is the sound of one hand
wiping
um no I would yeah I would wash my hands
yeah oh no if I'm if I'm if I'm at home
alone probably not
not a hand washer never washed hands not
I don't use soap I don't use shampoo you
don't have soap
I probably own some soap but I don't I'm
not a daily soap person
you have a girlfriend I go underwater in
the swimming pool not after you shine
your [__] after you wipe your ass you'll
go dive in the pool I will I'll try to
time it so it's not pool then [__] I
like to go [__] then pool so like will
you not even wipe if you poop and you
just go straight in the shower and let
the crumbs like fall on the floor come
on this is the most disgusting I should
have spooked just now yeah no you didn't
yeah in here not going anywhere but can
I ask you something I will do that move
but I don't I don't take showers per se
I mean I I take showers on on occasion
because what is what I'm saying yeah for
a reason that he can't remember I I
don't think you're any cleaner getting
out of the shower than I am getting out
of my pool because the shower you stand
over a oftentimes
um water saving low volume uh shower
head I'm completely underwater and in
the deep end for the for the length of
the pool I don't even want to go in your
pool your pool is probably the most
disgusting you take a [__] don't bite
yourself and then dive in yeah
pool water is very clean I think it's a
salt water system
not even chlorine I get out of the pool
I dry off with a towel I get dressed and
watch me towel do you take it there's a
towel go in the laundry rarely rarely
inner dolphin yeah as clean as a dolphin
I air dry the towel well how can the
towel be dirty I just got out of the
pool dry what do I got on me yeah I hang
it out I air dry it
if my if if anyone's around I'll wear
some shorts in the pool and then I air
dry the shorts and then the shorts are
clean everything's clean we you don't
you don't need all the soap all the
rubbing and the scrubbing you're single
now basically right
is this why is this why you're single
down I listen
thank you
[Music]